in Austin Texas
the City Council hired a consultant to
give a talk on women in government and
how to fight sexism that's they hired
him for which it sounds like a really
good thing but his talk ended up being
sexist oh boy yeah yes here's some of
the speech this is absolutely real
with a mayor for the first time having
to deal with all female commissioners do
men and women speak the same language
and I'm going to tell you upfront no
because they don't process things at the
same way that's the guy they hired to
help fight sexist all right to talk to
people about how to fight citizen well
anyway gotten confused and hired a pro
sick well anyway the speaker was fired
and since then the City of Austin is
still apparently having trouble finding
just the right speaker to give the
anti-sexism talk they keep trying take a
look I sincerely apologize for the
previous consultant I'm told his remarks
made many of you feel emotional that's
completely understandable especially
around that time of the Moon I'm sorry
that speaker was way out of line unlike
him I respect women in leadership after
all a woman's place is on top all right
I'm sorry you had to hear that I would
have been here sooner but I was stuck
behind a woman trying to park I mean
come on God please
oh that's okay I'll open it for you they
should have done this a long time ago
they finally asked a woman to administer
the sexism workshop I would never trust
a man to get this right
almost as much as I would never trust a
Jew hey thanks for watching be sure to
click subscribe to see even more great
cone and clips you may now return to
your pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography